while the pandemic is hurting many small
companies one business in Texas is
seeing the opposite effect
Julie Terrell Dawson has been driving
her cow painted ice cream bus through
the Fort Worth area for over a decade
now and now she says she's busier than
ever
Maria the AVL shows us how she's
delivering delivering a little bit of
normalcy and bringing communities
together in neighborhoods west of Fort
Worth Texas the sweet sounds of summer
are delivered by Julie beans
unmistakable ice cream truck when you
tell people what you do for a living I'd
remove the ice cream truck that looks
like a cow yes what's their reaction the
majority of people are super shocked
that that's even a thing or a job it's
cold
ten years ago Julie Terrell Dawson quit
her day job and started selling ice
cream to spend more time with her kids
when the corona virus pandemic hit she
had every intention of shutting down her
business and staying home then the calls
started snowball snowball effect
somebody saw somebody called somebody
booked somebody called Songbook it was
just a repeat rinse and repeat what is
it about ice cream that just is
resonating with people right now so ice
cream to a lot of people and to me is
kind of a comfort food
this comfort food has turned into a cash
cow for dawson giving joy to those
customers who've lost so much I have a
tinge bit of guilt sometimes when I
think about it because I do know so many
families that are not able to make money
right now businesses are suffering I've
seen a ton of my small business owners
even in my local cities that have had to
shut down are not coming back after
Corona hi Julie this is your first stop
here but you're going all day long all
day our last event today is cannot be
over until about 7:30 we just go from
neighborhood to neighborhood or birthday
party or wherever we're heading to for
all day long all day long all day long
all day long Julie beans to truck team
is now working seven days a week eight
hours a day
[Music]
what's better than ice cream it's warm
outside I mean it's a good time to have
ice cream and I love that the truck
actually says Happy Birthday Mulund on
during the months of April on May she
worked so much she brought in the same
amount of money in the first few months
of the pandemic then all of 2019
every Wednesday since school was
canceled back in March
families gather in this cul-de-sac
bonding over bomb pops in crunch bars
the way that we have gotten to know each
other and become closer friends as it's
kind of priceless for Julie this is a
calling that's become less about money
and more about doing her part during a
difficult time it makes people happy
right now I'm super excited and feel
very fortunate to be that person to
bring just a tad bit of happiness to
people for CBS this morning media vol 4
with Texas thanks Matteo who doesn't
love a bomb pop or a Dreamsicle or a
budge sickle I think it's Julie the ice
cream truck and ice cream it's just a
perfect storm of joy yeah wherever Julie
beam goes I love it I was wearing how
long that list was gonna go there yeah
it's got a lot of different kinds of ice
cream I don't know what I'm gonna get
this afternoon but I'm gonna get
something I scream you scream